there are many deities and spirits that
can be found all throughout the Greek
pantheon that have some kind of
association with war but there is only
one that is considered legal of war and
no I'm not referring to Kratos befall of
the hardcore go to war fans jump in the
comments to tell me dish guy is wrong
everyone knows that great joy before he
killed all of the cards no today's video
will be on Ares the actual god of war
for anyone who's already familiar of
Ares you know that he was one of the
twelve olympic deities the son of zeus
and hera
so the unbridled rage violent behavior
and constant need for bloodshed
definitely isn't a huge surprise
considering that his parents aren't
exactly known for their calm and
forgiving nature to the ancient Greeks
Ares embodied war he represented its
necessity and unpredictability but much
like war itself
Ares divided the Greek people he only
had a handful of cults and temples with
most been located in Sparta the Spartans
saw Ares as the perfect example of what
a soldier should be physically strong
resilient and well versed in combat all
things that we can associate back to the
God of War needless to say not all
Greeks agreed and it's quite fitting
that his largest worship took place in
Sparta with their biggest opposition
being the Athenians and Athena if the
role Ares plays in Greek mythology is
rather small and I think most of this
comes down to Athena being seen as
superior if you haven't already guessed
Athena and Ares or bitter rivals who
found themselves in constant competition
most of this comes down to the attitudes
and beliefs of the ancient Greek people
Ares represented what many Greeks strive
not to be whereas Athena was seen as
much more well-rounded she was calm
intelligent and highly skilled in
warfare
Athena represented the best of both
aspects the scholar and the warrior or
as Ares would have been seen as not much
more than a soldier so we can see that
the phenol was definitely favored to
areas in the eyes of the Greek people
but she was also a favorite of Zeus with
most of his father's praise an attention
being directed towards his sister we can
definitely see that this is something
Ares is affected by we do actually see
this directly addressed in book 5 of
Homer's Iliad where Ares accuses his
father of sure in favor towards Athena
claiming that it's because she was
physically born from Zeus and this might
actually be true but it might also be
because Athena did more than just wage
war the few appearances that Ares does
actually make I'm sure many of you have
guessed feature around war
conflict with the most famous being the
Trojan War which he was unfortunately on
the wrong side of with Athena once again
emerging the victor it was often said
that Ares wrote a chariot into
battlefield of his children so the app
would definitely default far from the
tree these children included Phobos
meaning fear demos meaning terror and n
yo who's often associated of discord but
who also appeared in numerous forms
depending on the story ranging from his
mother or sister to even one of his
numerous lovers together any own Ares
had one son named Annie alias whom was
said to replace his father as the god of
war and no Kratos didn't kill him either
there are some accounts of Ares or at
least what we can consider the God of
War existing during the time of the
Mycenaean Greek people where at times he
was actually referred to as in Yaya's so
the name has existed for some time and
generally has connotations of war
he also fathered the goddess Harmonia
who can discuss a bit later on and
address Tia the goddess of equilibrium
the female warrior tribe known as the
Amazons were also said to be direct
descendants of Ares who the most famous
example being hipolito who became Queen
when Ares gave her a magical girdle that
signified strength and authority the
sacred shrines of the Amazons who also
said to be guarded by the birds of Ares
which was said to have arrow like
feathers and were quite similar to the
magnet instant failure Birds slain by
Heracles the only story that really
features the birds of Ares is that of
Jason and his Argonauts when they came
across the birds during their quest for
the golden fleece when the birds rained
down their feathers Jason and his men
raised their shields to block the
endless volleys eventually using Spears
to poke the birds out of the sky and
drive the flock away in the stories
where eros is considered to be the son
of Aphrodite it's speculated that his
father was Ares which isn't really too
unreasonable if we consider the fact
that Aphrodite was a goddess associated
of love and Ares himself for someone
driven by intense emotion and passion to
then have children who are solely
associated of an emotion as powerful as
love does make some sense or at least it
does to me anyway there are a few
stories that Ares does make an
appearance in so let's start with the
one that I find most amusing the affair
with Aphrodite
so in order for Zeus to convince her
Festus to set his mother free he was
offered a marriage of Aphrodite
but as great as that may have been for
her Festus the goddess was left a
miserable and so when she noticed the
attention of Ares it wasn't long before
the two started their affair
which I'm sure we can all guess was
destined to end in disaster one day when
her Festus was away Aphrodite in Aries
was seen by the Titan Helios who then
told her Festus of what he had seen FSS
then did what most people seem to do in
that situation he decided that he would
catch them together and so he created an
invisible golden net that was designed
to ensnare them the next time Aphrodite
in Aries enjoyed each other's company
the booby trap was triggered and the two
were ensnared in a very compromising
position her Festus then decided that he
would drag them outside and invite all
of the gods and goddesses of Olympus to
witness them in this position and the
two were then thoroughly mocked and
ashamed but some gods did state that
they would happily trade places of Aries
as a testament to the beauty of
Aphrodite with Aphrodite in Aries now
totally embarrassed they had no choice
but to return to their respective cities
but her Festus wasn't quite finished
together Ares and Aphrodite had a
daughter known as Harmonia and when her
Festus heard that she was marrying
Cadmus he decided to attend the wedding
as a wedding gift he would offer her
money and necklace that he had crafted
himself this trinket will then be known
as a necklace of Harmonia and was said
to bring bad luck in disaster Kirstin
anyone in its possession another story
involving Ares details his interaction
was a to see Giants fel tez and Otis who
often referred to as the alo died one
day the two brothers came across the God
of War and decided they would kidnap him
and place him in a giant bronze jar
where he would remain for an entire
lunar year they would only let Ares go
if the goddess Artemis agreed to marry
one of them
Artemis did eventually make an
appearance and true to their word Aries
were set free but then the two brothers
began to argue as to who would marry her
whilst this was happening Artemis
transformed herself into a deer and
hopped him between the two eager to not
let Artemis escape the two brothers
threw their Spears accidentally impaling
each other because Giants are dumb for
the most part arias is described by
Homer has been fairly neutral during the
Trojan War but he did eventually join
the side of the Trojans after being
convinced by Aphrodite despite the
initial promise he made to Hera and
Athena to join the side of the Achaeans
when Diomedes initially saw Ares on the
battlefield he pulled his men back out
of fear but Athena would later order him
and his men to launch a full-scale
attack on Ares now face the face of Ares
Diomedes launched his spear and with the
guidance of Athena he impaled the god of
war who let out a scream so loud and
terrified
they calls those on both sides to
tremble in fear Aries now heavily
wounded had no choice but to flee and so
did the trojan forces knowing that
without the God of War they could not
win this battle when Aerys had heard the
news that his son ascalaphus had been
slain by the Trojans he was eager to
swap sides and join their canyons but at
this point in Sue's had forbidden any of
the Olympians from joining the wall and
when Aerys attempted to enter the battle
he was stopped by Athena when Zeus once
again allowed the gods to join the war
the first thing Aries did was attack
Athena seeking revenge for the previous
injury he had sustained but Athena would
once again best Ares by hurling an
enormous boulder at him yet another
example of Athena emerging victorious
over her brother something that I see
quite often in the comment section are
people asking me to cover the Roman
counterparts to these Greek deities and
it definitely seems to be some confusion
as to the similarities and differences
for the most part the Roman counterparts
are quite similar they do feature in
some different stories and have slightly
different behavior but I think the real
differences can be seen in how they were
perceived by the people of ancient
Greece and Rome and in some cases it
definitely gets quite interesting we saw
last video that Minerva is slightly
different to Athena but there is
definitely an interesting contrast
between Ares and his Roman counterpart
Mars we've established that Ares was
seen as a necessary evil but he was by
no means a popular god nor was he widely
worshipped by the ancient Greeks because
they instead favored Athena Mars however
was portrayed in a completely different
way to the Romans he was seen as a
protector in the same way that Athena
was similar to how in the Greek pantheon
Athena was only second to Zeus Mars was
only second to Jupiter where the Greeks
saw Ares is destructive the Romans saw
Mars as a peacekeeper the Romans highly
value their military so naturally it
makes sense that Mars was considered a
highly respected deity I think most of
this boils down to the difference in
ideas between the tube the Greeks were
quite abstract thinkers who placed a
heavy emphasis on philosophy cosmology
and metaphysics so deities like Ares
would have been seen as an unfortunate
necessity the Romans however believed in
the physical and practical
implementation of an idea they highly
valued manliness toughness of
physicality and war was seen as a way to
keep the peace which is why Mars is such
an integral figure to their set of
beliefs and mythology a point that I
think is definitely quite interesting is
that the Roman counterpart of Ares is
actually more similar to Athena than
Ares himself and the role that Mars
plays in the Roman pan
Theon is quite similar to that of Athena
in the Greek pantheon hopefully this
video has given you more of an insight
into the Greek god of war and if you
have enjoyed this video then please
consider leaving a thumbs up or maybe
even subscribing and hittin that pesky
pesky notification bell otherwise you'll
never know when I upload thanks you too
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained and here's
something for all of you go to war fans
out there to enjoy it was I who saved
you in your time of greatest need I
haven't forgotten Ares I remember how
you saved me that night I was trying to
make you a great warrior you succeeded
[Applause]
[Applause]
Kratos had done me impossible immortal
defeating of God Ares was no more